welcome to this video playing 10 a week
10 a week from Norway yeah recently
Magnus cards revealed that he is playing
on various accounts but Joshua this is
one of them using some of his friends
accounts as he has stated oh man
Knight to f5 yeah 35 t5 is a good move
here I think check I had this what not
even I wasn't even aware that this is
possible or is it d6
56 mm okay
[Music]
okay let's see what happens here
mmm the night only has age five to go mm
okay I can't take g7e takes c6
mm-hm this is probably not really enough
compensation
yeah it's d6 ya know T 595 is not a very
good move actually but okay so I'm what
two points that's quite a lot
is d6 young
amazing
night afore 93's is such a such a tough
decision maybe it is so rookie a tour
yeah problem yeah Bishop III probably
now have slight compensation no d5 is
hanging and so if you protect it it's
it's really getting very far behind and
development yeah
still he's doing that probably was some
justification how do I actually get get
ahead maybe maybe do it do it very
radically takes 95
this is still two points on four points
and I'm still two points down
you know k it's never enough for two
pawns
check not sure that this check is doing
him any good but maybe it's not really
muttering anymore it's probably good
whatever he's doing maybe we'll be able
to or something like that
I can take h2 maybe I should do that
simply grab this rather unimportant pawn
at least I got one of them one of them
back check
the eye is close to trapping my night
what this is actually trapping it unless
I have some sort of technical
counterplay bogey form no threatened job
I study can just move the King to maybe
King you one simply not sure what I do
after King in one okay
I decide didn't think of okay I can I
can go here Rock g5 king evade I have
roof - maybe night after check I mean at
some point
I can gently take here check because of
this trick and I've got equal material
again believe it or not
check check check check
I'm still somewhat a third yeah of
course yeah I mean it's a it's probably
four is still worse for me maybe I can
draw somehow but I can probably go to
the Acorn
yeah I just escaped a completely dead
position I just I made a mistake yeah I
played this I played this and this is
this is the move I forgot I really
forgot it I played this too quickly
whatever now his capture is very very
very dangerous farm for white this kind
of stuff is super super dangerous I have
played this a couple of times against my
way here being winning all the time
losing still because of some bloody
trick but it's a very good very good
position yeah d5 is probably a bit too
much maybe the computer wants to take
him yeah maybe you can you should try
that actually
it's possible yeah yeah this this looks
like a bit more compensation already I
get to e8 let's say something like that
this is this is something for example
taking as it's really too too dangerous
maybe something like that could be an
idea to to block him yeah in the game
I'm just I'm just losing I guess can
just try to to be irritating
check-check
[Music]
I mean here it seems that 96 is winning
I mean probably there are many ways that
lead to to win for white but here of
course it the computer check check check
is white it's a completely winning here
because of 96 still still gives white a
total win and there's also 95 possible
name hmm okay yeah and of course this is
through week yeah white is so winning
him he only sported a bit afterwards by
allowing King to his six check check you
know I'm okay again yeah he was very low
on time of course yeah well complicated
stuff but very lucky you resort for me
okay thanks for watching